well the Venezuelan government claims
that it wore tada plot to assassinate
sitting president Nicolas Maduro as the
country's political crisis escalates
vice president Mike Pence is heading to
Miami today where he's expected to drum
up support for opposition leader Juan
wydo Wanda why do says Venezuela special
forces intimidated his wife and infant
daughter at their home yesterday police
are denying the claim Elizabeth Palmer
is in Venezuela's capital of Caracas
Elizabeth good morning good morning this
gigantic political power struggle
playing out right now in Venezuela is
powered by the fury and the misery of
millions of people who not so long ago
had perfectly decent lives you know Ari
Gallegos is one of those his family now
scraped by on $10 a month what would you
say to America right now least help us
how long do we have to wait we're hungry
and we have nothing the people who
poured into the streets blamed President
Nicolas Maduro for bringing Venezuela to
its knees and Gallegos fears for his two
sons I hope that they leave the country
even so Ari Gallegos crutches and all is
planning to join tomorrow what promises
to be the mother of all anti Maduro
marches the Venezuelan opposition is
determined to ratchet up the pressure
now that the whole world is watching and
taking sides
Nora and world is watching Elizabeth
Palmer continuing your great reporting
there in Venezuela thank you